we have all sorts of products today you
know products that we sell at the daily
wire for products that you know are
wonderful advertisers have but then
there are some products that I don't
know I don't know that I can quite get
behind
Tampax so I've never I haven't used
Tampax myself uh you know I can't say
that I was a regular customer but Tampax
has a very strange advertising campaign
they launched this a couple of weeks ago
meant to get to it
fits in right now in the Christmas
shopping season
Tampax tweeted out
you're in their DMS we're in them we are
not the same
yeah
did I read that correctly
so obviously it's a it's like a sex joke
you know about
about the about women and about what
women use Tampax for
my first reaction was
why are tampons tweeting why do tampons
have to treat because all brands have to
Tweet now and All Brands Market
themselves on this kind of edginess
right they you have to tweet to sell the
product and the way to get attention on
social media as I think we've all seen
in the last 24 hours is to consistently
go and say the edgiest things that you
possibly can and this is not a great
long-term strategy
the entire culture is incentivizing us
to do that ever more and more but as a
long-term strategy that's it's not
really smart I talked about this on the
Matt frad show the other day
Matt fradd said Michael you're a
Catholic but you're also a conservative
talking head and so does does your
Catholic obligation to be charitable and
not to you know constantly go out and
detract from everybody does that
conflict with your role as a as a
professional owner of the libs and I I
thought you know maybe sometimes I hope
it doesn't but I'm sure we all messed up
sometimes but I generally try not to
because
if you
if you stake your
career or your brand or your
professional life I'm just constantly
being more and more offensive more and
more shocking more and more edgy not
only are you probably going to flame out
as happens to basically everyone who
attempts the strategy but it's also
going to lead you into saying things
that you probably don't really believe
that you
probably don't really think are totally
true you'll you'll just be incentivized
to do that for shock value
which is not a good way to live and it
will end up depriving you of your
integrity and of you know in in the name
of breaking through these uh strictures
and the censorship you're going to end
up saying things that you don't think
are true in the first place speaking of
weird sex stuff
headline
weird sex stuff and dishonesty headline
out of the BBC
trans woman jailed for sex with 14 year
old girl
what does that headline actually mean
I'm going to translate that headline
from woke politically correct dishonesty
into English
man arrested man jailed for raping child
that's what that really means from a
trans woman
jailed for sex with 14 year old girl
what do we call it when 25 year olds
have sex with 14 year olds do we call
that we just call that sex
no we usually call that rape that would
be statutory rape everywhere in the
United States or Britain or anywhere in
the Civilized world
and then what do we call a trans woman
in reality we call that a man but it
shows you the power of of language
which is a real hobby horse of mine but
you've got to constantly come back to it
because you
you think
because you are conscious and you read
the news and you know what's up and you
you get all of your information from
different sources you don't only believe
CNN you think that you can catch the
deception but you you can't none of us
can all the time because
so much of the leftist deception is
built into the very language that we use
when you use the phrase trans woman or
if you refer to a guy who thinks he's a
woman as she or even if you refer to a
guy who thinks that he's a woman with a
woman's name
you are consciously or unconsciously
accepting the premises
a woman has a right to go into the
woman's bathroom
she has a right to go into the woman's
bathroom
Caitlyn has the right to go into the
woman's bathroom when you accept terms
like gay marriage which even people who
oppose gay marriage often will use the
term gay marriage you are accepting a
premise that gay marriage is just a it's
a type of marriage you know you can have
American marriage or an Indian marriage
or a gay marriage but it's it's not the
whole the whole point of the debate is
that gay marriage is a contradiction in
terms and it's completely different
intrinsically it cannot be the same
thing as marriage
we do this constantly the undocumented
workers undocumented Americans
undocumented Americans are just a type
of American except they're not they're
foreign Nationals they're they're not
Americans justice-involved youth that's
one of my favorite academic euphemisms
for for criminal children you know
criminal minors or justice-involved
person is used to refer to adults
whatever justice-involved persons are
they are not involved with Justice
they're criminals they're involved with
Injustice actually it's a total
deception so you've got to be aware of
even if you're reading this you say wait
something's clearly gone wrong here it's
not a trait you've got to translate it
in your head and say it in your head in
order to really appreciate this trans
women jailed for sex with 14 year old
girl no no
grown man rapes child that's what it is
it's gonna get it'll give even you a
different and more accurate picture hey
there Mr Michael this is Stanley again
thank you for taking my original
question on your pronunciation of words
like divisive versus divisive I was
listening to your show and Ben also
brought it up on his show the Canadian
new laws that were going to try to help
with assisted suicide now I think the
reason the Canadians are actually doing
this as well as other European countries
with socialized medicine is because of
their social programs
it's obviously much cheaper to just do
away with them than it is to treat them
for a fatal illness you might remember
several years ago I think back in 2018
there was a little boy named Alfie Evans
and he died and he may have died anyway
but he died because the British
government would not allow his parents
to seek treatment for him even outside
of the country even the Vatican was
going to send a jet to help him now I
think honestly at the core of all of
this is Satan he hates the family and he
does everything he can to circumvent it
from gender confusion to making husbands
and wives thinks that they're a drag on
each other to pornography and all sorts
of things anyway that's my perspective
what do you think
it's a great question sometimes people
ask questions like that at uh speaking
events that I go to you know they'll get
up and they'll say hey Michael and give
a dissertation on their their view of
the world and say what do you think of
that I agree actually I agree with that
that's a very good one and especially on
your first point when you say Do you
think that Canada now
is pushing assisted suicide because it
will save the money because they've got
these sort of socialist programs and the
answer is of course yes this is one of
the great hazards to socialized medicine
do all sorts of socialist programs and
getting all of your political power away
and upending all sorts of traditions
because uh you just get perverse
incentives
and conservatives understand that
incentives motivate people's behavior
so if the government is going to create
an incentive
for granny maybe to
leave this planet a little sooner then
you're going to see more of that
behavior okay and we know that because
part of the debate over socialized
medicine and Obamacare and all the rest
of it was that people spend
a huge proportion of the money that they
will spend over their whole lives on
Health Care in the final 18 months of
their life
right it's not as though you spend the
same amount every year on Healthcare
it's that you spend basically nothing on
health care for most of your life and
then a little bit more as you get older
and then at the very end you spend a ton
of money so if you're some technocrat
with a green Vise or crunching the
numbers you say wow if we want to save
who knows 50 on our medical expenses in
the government if we just kill Granny 18
months sooner
you're going to get that behavior that's
a huge moral hazard make sure you head
on over to the member block we also have
fake headlines I need your help in in
Discerning which headlines are real so
if you are not a member click the link
in that description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]